il ya plus de cent dix mille logements
vacants à paris cette statistique de
l'insee permet peut être de comprendre
un peu mieux la crise du logement de
mieux comprendre également une de ses
principales conséquences le phénomène
squat l'occupation autrement dit
d'appartements vides ces squats sont
très divers certains sont politique très
dure il ressemble parfois des ghettos
d'autres sont plus calmes et ont même
des projets très sérieux exemple les
occupants rénovateurs dont certains ont
été expulsées la semaine dernière des
squatteurs particulier qui se défendent
avec des arguments très forts comme
l'expliquent ramon gutierrez
rue de l'ourcq une façade colorée des
tracts bref un squat tranquille et des
occupants plein d'idées qui n'entendent
pas se marginaliser occuper une maison
vide pour eux c'est enrichir la vie
associative du quartier faire respecter
un droit au logement tenter des formes
de vie nouvelle aux pouvoirs publics qui
les ont toléré ces dernières années mais
qui aujourd'hui affiche leur embarras
ils répondent que le rapport farce sur
l'insertion des jeunes propose la mise à
disposition des jeunes donc de lieu de
taille réduite susceptibles d'être des
lieux de rencontre cette définition est
la nôtre distille laissez nous donc
exister on des marchés des dettes en
constance liaison avec la population du
quartier aussi avec ses pouvoirs publics
pour essayer de
faire un travail sur sur l'insertion des
jeunes dans la société et sur sur les
problèmes de délinquance qu'on rencontre
un peu partout nous savons qu'un autre
gay terroristes ici c'est les amalgames
dont on essaye de se faire de se
convaincre le pouvoir il sert très bien
on est très bien connu des services de
police parce que tout simplement on va
discuter avec eux on a on est allé de
notre plein gré volontairement
s'entretenir avec le commissaire de
police de nos activités afin qu'il y ait
aucune équivoque et malgré tout ça
certaines personnes essayent de répondre
cette image sur où je pense que toutes
les personnes informées que ce soit
aussi bien la préfecture que le
commissaire à l'échelle du quartier que
les renseignements généraux que
tout se joue ce type de pouvoir
judiciaire et policier sarr très bien
que c'est ce sont des pure calomnie à
notre encontre étudiants pour certains
ouvriers ou employés pour d'autres tous
font preuve de réalisme témoins
l'imprimerie qu'ils ont monté voilà
trois ans à proximité du squat une
coopérative ouvrière installé dans les
locaux loués et qui a nécessité
l'obtention de prêts et
d'investissements
les occupants rénovateurs se veulent
organiser surtout depuis que 600
policiers ont procédé à l'expulsion de
14 d'entre eux dans un autre squat de la
rue de crimée parmi les expulsés
jean-pierre héberge actuellement rue de
l'ourcq
et a réfléchi parce qu'on a investi
beaucoup d'argent les gens démarrage et
que effectivement pour nous c'était
important que ce soit ailleurs
les rapports de travail aussi différent
comme à l'intérieur d'un autre avis tu
as tu vous n'êtes pas des jeunes
désoeuvrés nom n'est pas les jeunes
désoeuvrés au contraire ici on travaille
un peu plus que la normale on est loin
des portraits de terroristes style
action directe ou de l'aversion aux
squatteurs rasta mais leurs tribulations
ces dernières semaines se multiplient
pour eux les signes avant coureurs d'une
expulsion peut-être